par exemple caroline dites moi la taille
c'est important ah oui de quoi la taille
la taille la tâche this will then we
d'une personne comme une personne oui de
quoi vous voulez la date l'heure et
autres chambres ont été franchement
bardon il est quand même ça prête à
confusion bienvenue mais pas d'en bas du
jour
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
oui faire vous expliquer parce que voilà
on va aller voir du côté de c'est mon
choix
1 vous avez vraiment l'esprit mais vous
êtes vrais bruit m'a fait la
connaissance tout d'assurer une fine et
delphine elle a du mal avec les hommes
plus petit clou raconte le de ces
expériences vraiment ils ont l'esprit et
sur un réseau social en fait je traîne
avec beaucoup de motards
on avait des affinités donc franchement
on pensait qu'il y avait quelque chose
est en fait quand il a vu face à moi
j'ai pas pu vous avez discuté avec cet
homme pendant pas mal de temps
il est rendu compte que ça match et
entre vous c'est tu vas pas si mal dans
notre société et mais physiquement
jusqu'à 2,26 mètres ça va ça n'allait
pas au niveau des câlins voilà ça se
passe dans un lit pour pas mal de choses
ça me gêne 4 centimes à ses intimes est
[Applaudissements]
en fait l'amour c'est le physique pour
toi parfaitement lot de taille idéale
d'un homme peau selon les femmes c'est
un mètre 83 qui ferme à 83 km 89
prix 1 mètre 80 est ce que la taille du
monsieur sa taille 1 est ce qu'elle est
importante est ce que vous pourriez être
tombée follement amoureuse d'un garçon
qui est plus petit que vous écoutez est
ce que vous voulez qu'on fasse la
démonstration in situ je me mets à côté
de jimmy willy ensuite mon à côté de
thibault doit il aller voir tout de
suite qu'il ya un problème si je me mets
à côté de jimmy que j'ai des talons que
je suis bien que bas que j'ai envie de
sortir au restaurant les kabyles
imaginons que ce soit mon jeune ami mais
pas moi il ya quand même y'a quand même
battez vous admettez vous regardez moi
l'art ça soit gardée il ya quand même un
problème là il ya un problème c'est si
disons que ce soit à jimmy par exemple
et je vais au resto et des salles de
gênes ça veut dire la cible m
mais rassurez a besoin de protection
limitée dès qu'il pourra venir à
montceau cours d'art évidemment quand
vous alliez vous auriez besoin de
quelqu'un de plus grand que vous ban est
alors fait grand évident plus grand que
vous avec talon alors plus grand que moi
avec talons d'accord c'est très vrai
c'est quand même embêtant ch
en revanche ni un regret il ya en
revanche il ya une étude madame études
je vous assure qu'il ya des recherches
qui indique que les hommes plus petit
participent davantage aux tâches
ménagères
même si on va le faire c'est qu'un homme
de ménage non mais très sérieusement ça
veut dire que vous vous seriez interdit
de tomber amoureuse de votre part par
exemple du papa de vos enfants
oui s'il avait quelques centimètres de
moins que vous mais c'est pas moi c'est
une cerveau c'est comme ça c'est facile
à des critères de sélection un mac 90 et
pourtant intellectuellement il voyait il
vous fait rire vous le trouvez beaux
opéras mais il a quelques centimètres en
moins ça passe pas ça passe pas ni la
maîtrise c'est par ici faut des avalats
gagner de l'importance à mettre
complètement barré
fatigué et vous voyez c'est ça ma
voisine ali toujours dans des
discriminations malheureusement dans les
landes la discrimination à la terrasse
désolé alors tout comme l avant j'étais
un peu stupide et wej était toujours en
mode non minimum 10 cm de plus parce que
je vais le regarder comme ça je vais
avoir les étoiles et ou dans les yeux et
figurez-vous qui m'est arrivé exactement
chez moi il ya une expression qui dit
c'est ce que tu veux pas retrouvé devant
la porte de chez toi qui se retrouve au
fin fond de ton lit rougir eh bien c'est
exactement ce qui s'est passé alors que
vous avez offert aux fleurs du riz je
dépasse je pense que mon chéri à côté de
moi il ya limite chez les cheveux qui
dépasse un peu parce qu'il est petit ah
ben oui les petits billets les petits
comment il est petit pas de rang et pour
moi il est petit pas grand mais il est
en mode barak et vivent à la rue gosse
ça va très très bien en dessous niveau
taille mais vous êtes d'un nom mais ma
voisine pourrait leur corrélation est
complètement largué il est formidable
d'abord en étant petit a dit mec
formidable carole bouquet fait le ménage
c'est ça